bonjour à tous merci de nous retrouver
sur public sénat à suivre ce matin un
débat consacré aux nouvelles maladies
infectieuses émergentes à l'initiative
de ce débat la sénatrice ump du bas rhin
fabienne keller qui a consacré un
atelier de prospective à cette question
pour elle le nombre de ces maladies
progresse 335 nouvelles maladies
infectieuses émergentes ont été
identifiés dans la deuxième moitié du
20e siècle
elles ont souvent pour origine et bien
les animaux comme le chikungunya ou
encore les fièvre ebola
alors que faire en cas d'épidémie majeur
nos sociétés ils sont elles préparées
éléments de réponse avec ce débat et
bien mes chers collègues la séance et
reprise l'ordre du jour appelle le débat
sur les nouvelles menaces des maladies
infectieuses émergentes demande de la
délégation sénatoriale à la prospective
la parole est à madame fabienne keller
rapporteur de la délégation sénatoriale
à la prospective
madame la ministre monsieur le président
chers collègues j'ai le plaisir de vous
présenter un rapport qui m'a été confiée
par la délégation à la prospective
présidée par joël bourdin sur les
nouvelles maladies infectieuses
émergentes
ce travail fait suite à plusieurs
rapports sur des sujets liés
je voudrais citer notamment le rapport
de notre collègue alain milon sur
l'utilisation des fonds pour la grippe
h1n1 suite au rapport de la cour des
comptes qui s'appelle le gestion d'une
crise sanitaire la pandémie de grippe à
aux rapports de marie christine blandin
et jean pierre door sur la mutation des
virus et la gestion des pandémies de
2010 fait suite aussi à la commission
d'enquêté sénatoriale sur la grippe h1n1
on pourrait également faire référence au
rapport de nicole bricq sur les agences
sanitaires ainsi que celui du député
yves bur
à titre plus personnel j'avais été
sensibilisés à ce sujet des maladies
infectieuses émergentes en suivant le
projet de création d'une unité de
recherche et de formation à kinshasa le
bassin du congo est en effet un
territoire sur lequel dans lequel de
nombreuses maladies émergent
c'est ainsi que j'ai pu effectuer
différents déplacements dans les pays du
sud et participer à un symposium
organisé au japon nous avons pu
rencontrer dans le cours de ce travail
de très nombreux chercheurs et
praticiens européens mais aussi
africains et asiatiques et bon j'ai
consacré un certain temps à l'analyse de
la tuberculose en inde maladie dont je
reparlerai puisqu'elle revient sur nos
territoires européens
le à la fin du mois de mai dernier a été
organisé au sénat un atelier de
prospective entièrement retransmis par
la chaîne public sénat avec une centaine
de représentants des grandes disciplines
concernées des historiens des
philosophes les ethnologues des
communicants des épidémiologistes des
microbiologistes cliniciens des
géographes et bien entendu des
parlementaires et je veux
les remercie tous pour l'intérêt qu'ils
ont portés à ce sujet sensible
chacun d'entre eux a pu intervenir
puisque chacun et trois minutes et
c'était absolument passionnant de voir
le croisement des regards sur ce sujet
sensible des maladies infectieuses la
menace des maladies infectieuses et
profondément ancré dans la mémoire des
populations
la dernière grande pandémie grippale de
1918 reste très présente dans les
esprits
ça fait un peu de littérature comme
l'illustrent magnifiquement ces lignes
écrites par jérôme ferrari dans son
roman le sermon sur la chute de rome
je cite un vent fétide se levait et
portait depuis la mer et les plaines
insalubres les miasmes d'une grippe
mortelle
balayant les villages et jetant par
dizaines dans les fosses creusées à la
hâte
ceux qui avaient survécu à la guerre
sans que rien n'ait pu l'arrêter comme
la mouche venimeuse des légendes
anciennes
cette mouche née de la putréfaction d'un
crâne maléfique et qui avait surgi un
matin du néant de ses orbites vides pour
exhaler son haleine empoisonné et se
nourrir de la vie des hommes jusqu'à
devenir si monstrueusement grosse son
ombre plongeant dans la nuit des valises
entières que seule la lance de
l'archange pu enfin la terrasse et
l'archange avait depuis longtemps
regagner son séjour céleste d'où ils
restés sourds aux prières et aux
processions il s'était détourné de ceux
qui mouraient à commencer par les plus
faibles les enfants les vieillards et
les femmes enceintes ça la citation
pour autant on peut aujourd'hui se poser
la question de savoir s'il faut encore
attaché une attention particulière à des
maladies qui ont disparu ou que l'on
sait désormais traités grâce aux prod au
progrès de la médecine depuis un siècle
la vaccination ou la découverte des
antibiotiques chers collègues ou aussi
grâce à l'amélioration de la nutrition
après tout à l'exception du sida qui a
continué de faire près de deux millions
de morts l'an dernier les décès dus à
ces maladies ne représente plus et c'est
heureux qu'un pourcentage faible de la
totalité des décès bien inférieurs à
ceux imputables aux accidents de la
route au diabète ou à l'alcoolisme à ne
s'en tenir qu'aux statistiques la cause
serait entendu et on pourrait imaginer
que l'intérêt persistant pour ces
maladies ne relève en définitive que de
l'inconscient collectif de ses peurs
chers collègues irraisonnée qui
franchissent la barrière des générations
et qui nous renvoie aux ténèbres de
l'humanité néanmoins je voudrais
insister
les spécialistes continuent de
s'inquiéter
à l'occasion de la pandémie grippale
h1n1 de 2009
le ms a lancé la première alerte
sanitaire mondiale il alerte sanitaire
du strass en 2002 a causé la mort de 500
personnes mais seulement quelques mois
et elle a mis en émoi toute la
communauté scientifique en son temps
comme le disent si bien les chercheurs
de l'institut pasteur nous avons eu de
la chance parce qu'il s'agissait d'un
virus très dangereux mais heureusement
faiblement contagieux et à incubation
lente
il en aurait été tout autrement avec un
virus toujours très contagieux mais très
dangereux et à incubation rapide et
c'est bien ce qui frappe le plus dans
l'observation des pandémies
c'est à la fois la particularité de
chaque type de maladie et la globalité
de ses effets susceptible d'atteindre
désormais l'ensemble de la population
mondiale
dans le contexte actuel de la
multiplication des transports de
personnes des échanges de biens et de
services
partage évidemment chers collègues le
point de vue du président de la
république qui observaient le mois
dernier lors de l'inauguration du
nouveau centre des maladies infectieuses
émergentes de l'institut pasteur à paris
que les virus franchissent les
frontières sans présenter leurs papiers
d'identité
car c'est bien là le point central de
notre si j'ai les maladies infectieuses
sont chaque année même en l'absence
d'épidémie déclarée aller à l'origine
d'au moins 14 millions de décès dans le
monde 90 % de ces décès surviennent dans
les pays du sud où ils représentent 43%
des mort par maladie c'est bien sûr
beaucoup plus faible dans l'eure les
pays du nord mais leur occurrence a
progressé de 10% dans les pays du nord
autour de ces quinze dernières années
de la même manière le nombre de maladies
émergentes est en progression
335 nouvelle maladie découverte entre
1940 et 2004 60% d'entre elles sont
d'origine animale parmi lesquels les
trois quarts proviennent de la faune
sauvage les virus les plus connus le
chikungunya le monkey pox lorteau virus
les fièvre ebola ou les fièvre de la
vallée du nil qui n'ont été identifiés
qu'à partir de la deuxième moitié du
xxème siècle dans les mêmes temps
l'efficacité des antibiotiques découvert
au xxème siècle diminue de manière
drastique
il n'est pas anodin de signaler
qu'aucune nouvelle classe
d'antibiotiques n'a été élaboré depuis
30 ans face à des épidémies majeures
neuf sociétés pourraient ainsi se
trouver fort dépourvues
l'espoir des chercheurs résidents le
séquençage à haut débit de nouveaux
virus que l'on sait faire maintenant
facilement
bien avant que d'envisager de longs mois
parfois des années avant leur
exploitation ne serait donc disponible
pour faire face à la crise sanitaire que
des médecins au fond très traditionnelle
de santé publique comme la quarantaine
les mesures élémentaires d'hygiène
ou les changements de pratiques ou de
comportements quotidiens pour autant nos
sociétés sont elles prêtes à se
soumettre à ce type de changement
pourrait-on appliquer ces mesures
traditionnelles dans notre société du
xxième siècle complexe mobile éclaté
parcellisé en crise dans le port de
marseille on laissait les navires isolés
pendant de longs mois pour que les gens
meurent de fut avant de les autoriser à
accoster
comment communiquer efficacement sur le
risque et sur l'incertitude
compte tenu des nouveaux médias et
notamment d'internet
comment garantir un accès équitable aux
ressources en cas de crise dans les
sociétés démocratiques tels sont les
réflexions qui justifie à tout le moins
un début de réflexion et de mise en
commun des uns des expériences des uns
et des autres chercheurs cliniciens mais
aussi médecins journalistes
transporteurs responsable de la sécurité
et bien sûr politiques pour dessiner les
évolutions possibles et pour identifier
les principaux leviers d'action le
travail a consisté à examiner les
tendances des principaux facteurs ou
variable propice aux émergences gelé
balaierait rapidement le premier d'entre
eux est évidemment liée à l'évolution de
la population mondiale qui dépasse
aujourd'hui 6 milliards et demi et
comptera d'ici 2050 9 milliards
d'habitants et habitants surtout
concentrés dans de vastes mais
mégalopole où les transmissions
interhumaines deux virus sont facilitées
deuxième facteur les pratiques agricoles
la déforestation les élevages intensifs
ceux de port en particulier les
déplacements d'animaux entre les forêts
et les villes modifié les écosystèmes et
favorise les contacts entre les hommes
et la faune sauvage notamment en afrique
et en asie je rappelle tout à l'heure
deux tiers des maladies proviennent des
animaux il ya ensuite la mondialisation
des échanges des personnes et des biens
qui contribue à la diffusion de vecteurs
épidémique comme les moustiques à
l'origine de l'apparition du chikungunya
dans le sud de la france
notre ami l'aèdes albopictus qui est un
petit moustique a été transporté dans le
sud de la france ou du virus de la
vallée du nil
aux états unis on peut signaler aussi le
facteur du changement climatique qui
expliquent le pullulement des bactéries
borelli agent de transmission de la
maladie de lyme dans le sud de
l'allemagne et dans l'est de la france y
compris désormais aux portes de la
capitale en forêt de sénart on peut
noter aussi le facteur de développement
déplacement des populations notamment en
afrique les réfugiés soit qu'elles y
soient obligés pour quitter un
environnement devenu trop aride pour
leurs troupeaux soit qu'elles soient
chassés de leurs terres d'attache par
des conflits ethniques des guerres
civiles ou simplement la pauvreté enfin
on peut citer l'évolution défavorable de
certains comportements recours excessif
aux antibiotiques dont on sait pourtant
qu'il accroît le phénomène de résistance
ou le rejet de la vaccination et on ne
peut que déplorer la persistance de ce
rejet
notamment quand il vient du milieu
médical lui même les conséquences de ses
principaux facteurs nous les connaissons
on constate aujourd'hui la réapparition
de maladies que l'on croyait oubliée la
peste le choléra conférer haïti la
tuberculose
en région parisienne la diphtérie la
rougeole la coqueluche
j'ai prêté une attention toute
particulière aux exercice de prospective
menée à l'étranger notamment au
royaume-uni ou en asie avec les travaux
menés en chine et par l'organisation
économique de la zone asie pacifique à
la suite de l'épidémie de sras saint ils
se sont mobilisés pour être mieux
préparé à la reproduction d'un événement
de ce type
j'en ai conclu à la lecture de ces
travaux de prospective très approfondie
qu'il est impossible d'identifier les
scénarios globaux tant les évolutions
des maladies sont complexes en fonction
de chaque facteur selon les zones
géographiques le climat les choix
politiques effectués sur des variables
qui peuvent être volontariste
satisfaisante tendancielle ou négative
je vous invite d'ailleurs nous avons
créé un blog sur ce sujet et il y à un
petit jeu de simulation
d'une pandémie absolument effrayant où
vous prenez fait des choix politiques et
vous voyez comment la pandémie se
diffuse et le nombre de victimes cela
permet de d'intérioriser là et de
simuler l'effet de différents acteurs et
de circonstance sur l'évolution et la
diffusion de la maladie
il nous faut donc chers collègues
reconnaître notre ignorance sur le
scénario auquel nous pourrons être un
jour confronté comme l'écrivait déjà de
manière prophétique
le microbiologiste français charles
nicolle en 1922
je cite il y aura donc des maladies
nouvelles
c'est un fatal un autre fait aussi
fatale et que nous ne serons jamais les
dépister dès leur origine
lorsque nous aurons notion de ces
maladies elles seront déjà toutes formes
et adultes pourrait-on dire
elles apparaîtront comme athènes a paru
sortant toute armée du cerveau de zeus
comment les reconnaîtrons nous ces
maladies nouvelles cops comment
soupçonne aurions-nous leur existence
avant qu'elles n'aient revêtu leur
costume de symptômes
il faut bien se résigner à l'ignorance
des premiers cas évident ils seront
méconnu confondus avec des maladies déjà
existantes
et ce n'est qu'après une longue période
de tâtonnement que l'on dégagera le
nouveau type pathologique du tableau des
affections déjà classé c'est la raison
pour laquelle j'ai la conviction
profonde que le seul scénario
convaincant tout cas le scénario
importants auxquels il ya lieu de se
préparer par des exercices
d'anticipation et celui du scénario
catastrophe c'est à dire celui d'une
maladie jusque là inconnu à incubation
rapide à forte létalité à transmission
interhumaine par voie aérienne à
distance plutôt courte et pour laquelle
on ne dispose d'aucun traitement
on ne peut évidemment s'empêcher de
penser à un acte de bioterrorisme
associant dans un triptyque infernal le
strass la grippe pandémique et la
dissémination de la variole contre
laquelle je le rappelle la population
mondiale n'est plus protégé c'est
pourquoi nous avons dressé dans le
rapport de la délégation unie
de 53 propositions établies sur la base
des recommandations faites par les
spécialistes consultés notamment ceux
qui s'étaient penchés sur les
perspectives des maladies émergentes en
santé humaine sous l'égide du haut
conseil de la santé publique en 2011
j'ai également identifié des leviers
d'actions auxquelles pourraient recourir
les pouvoirs publics
si je devais résumer en trois mots
l'ensemble de ces propositions se serait
et les journalistes ont bien relevé
informer prévenir coordonnées pour ce
qui concerne la préparation de la
société il est essentiel de tenir compte
des contraintes des populations si l'on
souhaite promouvoir la prévention et la
réaction
comment construire un modèle dynamique
interactif flexible la réponse passe par
le recours aux modes de communication
offertes par les nouveaux outils de
l'internet sur ce point tous chers
collègues restent à faire pour ce qui
concerne les choix politiques
les actions à entreprendre sont
nombreuses il convient d'adapter les
systèmes de santé en concevant des
outils d'alert adapté en organisant hors
des périodes d'épidémie en période de
paix comme disent les sociologues la
gouvernance que ces systèmes devront
respecter pendant la crise sanitaire en
renforçant les soins la recherche et la
formation dans les pays du sud
troisième axe en définissant les
priorités de la recherche sur les
maladies infectieuses
ces priorités ne pouvant relever de la
décision de la seule décision des
industriels de la santé
sur ce point on voit par exemple que
pour la tuberculose on est très mal
outillés parce que comme cette maladie a
concerné pendant longtemps seulement les
pays du sud
elle ne concernait pas des territoires
pour lesquels la demande était solvable
ainsi nous avons pris plus de dix ans de
retard en ce qui concerne la prévention
de la tuberculose
j'ai mené ce travail de réflexion et d'
enquête avec une équipe restreinte mais
avec l'aide désintéressée très efficace
des chercheurs praticiens universitaires
des principales disciplines concernées à
qui je renouvelle l'expression de ma
gratitude et j'en profite
saluer le professeur catherine leport
qui dirige un groupe de travail du haut
conseil de la santé publique sur ce
sujet et qui suit nos débats dans les
tribunes mais je suis consciente que ce
travail reste très en deçà de ce qui
pourrait être un exercice national de
prospective qui mettrait en relation
tous les métiers et toutes les
professions les professions concernées
avant que ne survienne une nouvelle
pandémie
c'est à ce type d'exercice que sont les
se sont livrés les britanniques en 2002
avec l'appui d'environ 300 spécialistes
réunis autour d'une dizaine de thèmes
centraux c'est un exercice assez
comparable que les etats-unis mènent
systématiquement chaque année c'est
pourquoi madame la ministre je me
permets de plaider auprès de vous pour
que notre pays s'engage dans la même
voie pour faire ce travail de fond
coordonné par une équipe restreinte
pluridisciplinaire les représentants de
toutes les professions concernées à
prendre est d'abord à se connaître
peut-être à se respecter chacun dans
leur discipline à échanger leurs
pratiques et à développer des réflexes
communs je pense aux professions de la
santé bien sûr publics mais aussi privés
à commencer par la médecine 2 il s'est
souvent eux qui ont la connaissance des
premiers symptômes
pour lesquels on n'identifie pas encore
la maladie mais aussi les professions de
la sécurité les professions de la
communication les professionnels des
transports puisque de nombreux
pathogènes arrive par les transports de
marchandises aussi les professionnels
des collectivités territoriales les
villes les départements qui peuvent être
concernés par les mesures à mettre en
oeuvre les professionnels de
l'enseignement ceux du tourisme très
concerné par les déplacements ses
représentants se concerterait dans
plusieurs groupes de travail sur
quelques exercices de simulation par
exemple marc simuler h1n1 qu'est ce
qu'on aurait pu mieux faire
avec peut-être des variantes notamment
sur la létalité de la maladie sur sa
gravité
on peut aussi simuler le
développement du chikungunya dans le sud
ouest de la france mais on pourrait
aussi travailler sur des thématiques
transversales comme l' usage des réseaux
sociaux en phase épidémique
la thématique des règles de la
communication de crise
la thématique de la médecine des voyages
notamment pour les destinations les plus
à risque enfin une thématique sur
l'interaction entre la santé humaine et
la santé animale et à cet égard je
voudrais dire toute la compétence qui
existent aujourd'hui notamment à l'inra
sur le thème de la santé animale et
peut-être qu'on aurait des progrès à en
tirer sur la question de la santé
humaine et compte tenu du risque de
transmission c'est en plus très
intéressant
je forme le voeu que cet exercice de
prospective également souhaité en
conclusion du séminaire du mois de
décembre dernier du val de grâce du haut
conseil de la santé publique créé à
l'initiative de ce spécialiste des
maladies infectieuses émergentes et qui
regroupe les agences sanitaires
françaises et de nombreux autres
partenaires d'autres professions
reçoivent madame la ministre
un accueil favorable de la part du
gouvernement les moyens à mettre en
oeuvre pour réaliser cet exercice sont
modestes et il permettrait sans doute
d'éviter dans le futur des dépenses et
surtout des dégâts humains bien plus
considérables faute d'anticipation d'un
événement hélas prévisible et je ne
doute pas madame la ministre que vous
aurez à coeur de nous apporter
d'apporter surtout à nos concitoyens des
assurances et des engagements sur ce
point chers collègues je vous remercie
pour votre attention
merci madame fabienne keller la parole
est à monsieur joël bourdin président de
la délégation sénatoriale à la
prospective
cette jolie
monsieur le président madame la ministre
madame la rapporteure chers collègues je
suis particulièrement heureux ce soir
pour la première fois depuis sa création
en 2009
notre délégation sénatoriale à la
prospective
l'un de nos rapports et les honneurs
d'un débat en séance publique
l'avion cible ici tu es auprès de la
conférence des présidents
voici plusieurs semaines en raison du
sujet éminemment sensible exposé à
l'instant avec talent le talent qu'on
lui connaît par notre collègue que
fabienne keller l'amener à cette idée me
qui est évidemment un risque auquel tous
nos concitoyens sont potentiellement
exposés et contre laquelle ils attendent
du gouvernement et de l'ensemble des
pouvoirs publics les mesures de
protection et de prévention qu'une
situation aussi grave exigerait c'est
pourquoi j'appuie avec beaucoup de
détermination
la demande notre rapporteur en faveur de
la conduite d'un exercice de prospective
grandeur nature pour que chacun soit
préparée sur le terrain et non pas
simplement en théorie à y faire face
nous attendons donc avec grand intérêt
la réponse que nous fera dans quelques
instants sur cette préconisation la
ministre en charge de la santé
je profiterai du temps de parole que je
dois ma qualité de président de la
délégation à la prospective pour donner
quelques indications sur le travail que
nous effectuons original peut-être
l'ignorez vous mais cette structure est
une spécificité de notre assemblée au
sein du parlement puisque l'assemblée
nationale n'a pas de commission ni
délégation à la prospective encore jeu
pourtant souligné l'importance de la
prospective c'est à dire cette recherche
approfondie aussi scientifique que
possible grâce à la construction de
scénarios de ce que pourrait être notre
société notre économie
notes population à un horizon très
lointain
en tout cas plus lointain que
l'annualité imposé par le vote de nos
lois financières
le parlement finlandais précurseur l'a
d'ailleurs parfaitement perçu puisqu'il
est il a déjà constitué en son sein une
commission permanente de l'avenir qui
s'y consacre intégralement et le premier
ministre finlandais lorsqu'il prononce
son discours annuel de l'union doit
présenter une vision de la finlande à 15
ans c'est à dire que la prospective est
vraiment dans la culture désormais du
parlement finlandais
nous n'en sommes pas encore là dans
notre pays même si j'observe que de plus
en plus d'entreprises du ministère
d'institutions se dote désormais de
cellule de réflexion à long terme
al'inverse nous avons plutôt le
sentiment nous parlementaires de voter
le plus souvent dans l'urgence des
mesures de court terme qui opacifient et
rendent plus complexes une vision
globale des choses
à échéance plus lointaine la suppression
du commissariat général du plan
en 2006 2006 nous a probablement priver
d'un outil précieux pour apprécier les
enjeux de long terme
certes son mode de fonctionnement
pouvaient sembler dépassée dans le
contexte de mondialisation et de
globalisation économique
certes il avait quelque peu vieilli mais
peut-être aurait-on pu envisager
simplement de le réformer
nous avons pris conscience de cet état
de fait
notamment grâce à la sensibilisation de
notre collègue jean pierre raffarin qui
comme ici à la délégation a prospecté
nous a montré du doigt le problème du
plan c'est la raison pour laquelle notre
délégation vient de tenir le 5 décembre
dernier une grande réunion sur le thème
de l'avenir de la planification
stratégique
cette réunion de travail a été organisée
conjointement avec le conseil économique
et social et environnemental qui une
année après
nous a également créé en son sein une
structure dédiée à la prospective et à
l'évaluation des politiques publiques
publierons d'ici deux semaines
le résultat des débats très instructif
tenu à cette occasion
j'observe d'ailleurs pour m'ont félicité
que le gouvernement a établi le même ce
constat que le nôtre puisque avant l'été
le premier ministre a fait état lors de
la grande conférence sociale de la
nécessité de disposer au niveau national
d'une structure de réflexion prospective
à même d'aider à la prise de décision
politique
il a confié d'ailleurs à cet effet à une
commission présidée par madame yannick
moreau le soin d'y réfléchir sur le
fondement de son rapport rendu le mois
dernier
il devrait donc être créé prochainement
un commissariat à la prospective et à la
stratégie dont nous suivrons évidemment
l'installation et les débuts avec la
plus grande attention
pour conclure je souhaite bien
évidemment que cette première expérience
de débat public sur les travaux de notes
délégation soit suivie par d'autres
nous voulons d'ailleurs adopté hier un
rapport consacré à l'avenir des
campagnes auxquelles je ne doute pas que
mes chers collègues sénateurs soit tout
particulièrement attachés et qui
pourrait faire utilement l'objet d'
échanges au sein de notre ennemi si je
vous remercie
merci monsieur le président alors avant
de démarrer enfin dans la suite du débat
bien sûr il ya les orateurs je voudrais
simplement dire que je vais lever la
séance à 19h20 19h25
lorsqu'il ya des vieux chais le premier
ministre madame la ministre souhaite s'y
rendent ce que nous comprenons madame la
ministre
des collègues également aussi ici donc
ce que je vous demande c'est de
respecter tout simplement le temps de
parole et nous aurons terminé à 19h20
tranquillement voilà donc dans la suite
du débat la parole est aux orateurs des
groupes
tout d'abord madame isabelle pasquet
et pour le groupe crc monsieur le
président madame la ministre mes chers
collègues le sujet abordé à l'occasion
de ce débat et qui a fait l'objet d'un
rapport d'information de la part de
fabienne keller notre collègue dans le
cas de la délégation sénatoriale à la
prospective est un sujet
particulièrement intéressant et je me
réjouis d'ailleurs que ce rapport
malgré une méthodologie pouvant
potentiellement mener au catastrophisme
soit qu'au contraire sur les causes
comme sur les risques possibles d'une
grande mesure
ce sujet fait depuis quelques années
l'objet de nombreux travaux de nature
scientifique madame keller lesar cité
cet intérêt légitime résultats sans
doute de la recrudescence de crise de
sanitaires durant les dernières années
est liée précisément à des maladies
infectieuses émergentes ou réémergente
disant cela je pense par exemple au
rapport rendu public en 2010 par le haut
conseil de la santé publique et intitulé
les maladies infectieuses émergentes
état de la situation et perspectives
les chercheurs n'ignore rien de la
situation et des différentes évolutions
possibles
voulant éviter d'être redondant avec ses
études et afin de me permettre aux
parlementaires ainsi qu'à l'ensemble des
décideurs publics de prendre les
meilleures décisions
la rapporteur a fait le choix judicieux
d'une prospective nom scientifique cela
nous apparaît pertinent et correspondre
aux besoins de notre pays
c'est d'ailleurs la voie empruntée
récemment par d'autres pays voisin du
nôtre comme le royaume uni sur la base
de ce travail dont chacun s'accordera à
reconnaître la qualité notamment ce qui
permet à toutes et tous de mesurer les
enjeux liés aux maladies infectieuses
émergentes
même en l'absence de connaissances
médicales la rapporteure formule dix
propositions auquel nous souscrivons
pour autant bien que pertinente et
reprenant une partie des préconisations
formulées par le passé par d'autres
organes
comme l'organisation mondiale de la
santé nous regrettons que ces
recommandations ne soit la plus
ambitieuse
pour notre part nous considérons que ces
dits préconisations ne doivent pas
constituer l'achèvement de la réflexion
en la matière mais au contraire servir
de point de départ pour nous permettre
d'appréhender le sujet à la hauteur de
son importance et pour nous inciter à
élaborer des projets politiques
susceptibles de réduire à la fois des
risques et les facteurs facilitant ou
déclenchant aussi pour illustrer mes
propos je vais prendre quelques exemples
la seconde préconisations de ce rapport
suggère d'agir sur tous les facteurs
d'émergence et de propagation des
maladies infectieuses pour ralentir ou
mieux inverser les grandes tendances
observées
nous pouvons que souscrire à cette
proposition même si nous craignons que
sans mesures concrètes s'inscrivant dans
une autre politique économique
financière et de coopération et ne reste
qu'un voeu pieux
comment par exemple s'attaquer à la
misère qui constitue un facteur majeur
de propagation des maladies émergentes
infectieuses sans rompre radicalement
avec les politiques qui endettent les
pays du sud et les privent de toute
capacité d'action le processus de
réduction de la dette des pays les plus
pauvres est notable mais largement
insuffisant
les pays en développement ont passé des
années à rembourser des milliards de
dollars de dettes
les privant des capacités d'action
la situation est telle que de nombreux
pays ont fini par dépenser plus à
rembourser leurs anciennes dettes qu
investir dans la santé et l'éducation
réunis le cas du lesotho et frappant ce
pays à payer 47 millions de dollars à
ses créditeurs en 2006 une somme qui
correspond aux deux tiers de l'aide au
développement que ce pays reçoivent
chaque année la huitième proposition de
notre collègue de réguler les mouvements
de praticiens de la santé des pays du
sud vers les pays du nord afin d'éviter
que ces derniers ne souffrent de déserts
médicaux d'origine économique est là
encore pertinentes
or pour ce faire il faudrait que la
communauté
et internationale prenne des décisions
ambitieuses tout doit être mis en oeuvre
pour opter pour soutenir le
développement de structures sanitaires
de proximité voulue construite et dirigé
par les populations locales
cette volonté est en totale
contradiction avec les politiques menées
conjointement par le fmi
l'om c est la réserve fédérale
américaine c'est trois institutions ne
consente à aider financièrement les pays
les plus pauvres qu à condition que leur
état au père des réductions budgétaires
massives qui privatise et ouvre des
secteurs enseignement public à des
entreprises privées dont la plupart ne
sont pas nationales le domaine de l'eau
potable de l'éducation de la santé sont
parmi les plus concernés un article de
marianne qui date de 2010 relate comment
ce mécanisme de ses produits aux
philippines et les conséquences sur la
population dans ce pays le système de
santé public a longtemps été réputée
comme performant les pauvres ils étaient
bien soignés gratuitement dans les
années 80 le gouvernement a sous
l'impulsion des institutions financières
internationales privatiser le système
depuis les malades pauvres ne sont plus
soignés et salaires des personnels de
santé non plus évolué la masse salariale
a été limitée et les investissements
matériels réduit au maximum
l'article de conclure cette situation a
provoqué une pénurie de personnel encore
plus grave car les étudiants en médecine
partait directement pour l'étranger dans
l'espoir d'y trouver de meilleures
conditions et un meilleur salaire
sur une période de 10 ans qui a suivi la
privatisation plus de 5000 infirmiers et
ses 1000 médecins sont partis à
l'étranger
de fait de nombreux hôpitaux ont fermé
ou ont réduit leurs activités par manque
d'effectif nous soutenons également
l'idée qu'il faut pour limiter les
risques
repenser au plan mondial les politiques
agricoles la déforestation massive en
amazonie andenne en indonésie à
madagascar en afrique tropicale
principalement justifié par le besoin
d'extension des productions agricoles
destinés à la fabrication
d'agrocarburants ou d'huile de palme est
un facteur aggravant
qu'attend donc pour exiger de l'om c'est
de l'om est-ce qu'ils interdisent la
vente de ses produits dans tout le monde
sait qu'en plus de leur rôle en matière
de développement des maladies
infectieuses
ils sont dangereux pour la santé et
abîme considérablement la planète
qu'attendons nous pour soutenir
également de manière massive de les
projets agricoles destinées dans les
pays du sud a redonné aux terres leur
vocation initiale dont celle de nourrir
la population locale en 2010 au ghana la
quasi totalité de la production avec
cole étaient destinés à l'exportation et
le pays à importer du riz d'amérique
alors qu'il en exporter il ya seulement
dix ans ce système affament les peuples
la malnutrition qui fragilise les
populations déjà exposé et 1 et de
conséquence de la transformation des
matières premières en valeur spéculative
au nom d'une seule règle la loi des
marchés
il faut également revenir à une
agriculture plus raisonnable favorisant
des circuits courts et avec une
utilisation raisonnée des pesticides et
des antibiotiques dans les élevages
on ne peut pas tout à la fois regretté
l'usure des sols sur lesquels les
maladies prospère dénoncer la réduction
permanente de l'efficacité de
l'antibiothérapie sur les humains et
dans le même temps continuer à soutenir
économiquement et favoriser les élevages
en batterie qui par définition pour
faire face aux risques élevés de mort
des animaux et donc de perte financière
recourt massivement aux antibiotiques
faute de temps je ne peux développer ici
ses réflexions sur d'autres sujets comme
les conséquences par ailleurs signalé
dans le rapport de notre collègue et je
l'en vide ici du réchauffement
climatique sur l'accroissement des
risques infectieux
mais chacun aura compris le sens de mon
intervention
les propositions contenues dans le
rapport sont justes mais elles ne
peuvent être pertinents pertinentes et
pleinement efficace que dans un
important changement de société de
repères et de priorité que pour notre
part nous appelons de nos voeux et que
nous n'avons de cesse de défendre dans
ces lieux je remercie
merci madame pas ce qu'est la parole est
à monsieur hervé marseille
pour le groupe udi uc
bonjour
monsieur le président madame la ministre
mes chers collègues
ce débat fait suite au rapport de notre
collègue fabienne keller au nom de la
délégation de la prospective
certains pourront trouver ce rapport
préoccupant très préoccupant ne
choisissons plutôt de le voir au
contraire encourageant encourageant
d'abord d'un point de vue formel comme
l'a dit notre collègue président de la
délégation il ya quelques instants
c'est un débat qui est une première et
qui valide la démarche une démarche qui
est pertinente et qui est importante et
je voudrais aussi féliciter d'emblée
fabienne keller pour la qualité du
travail qu'elle a réalisé
mais si au delà de la forme ce rapport
est pour nous et à nos yeux encourageant
c'est aussi pour des raisons de fond
d'abord parce que la menace est réelle
l'histoire des maladies infectieuses
nous l'enseignent régulièrement un agent
pathogène provoque une pandémie
meurtrière
l'une des dernières en date est des plus
impressionnantes celle de la grippe
espagnole a fait je le rappelle plus de
morts que la première guerre mondiale à
peu près mais poc l'hypothèse d'une
pandémie majeure et comme la survenue
d'une météorite tueuse ou d'une giga
éruptions volcaniques
l'une des grandes menaces naturelles
pesant sur l'humanité le catastrophisme
hollywoodien s'en est d'ailleurs
régulièrement inspirer encore récemment
avec un très bon film sur le sujet
contagion film glaçant qui rend
parfaitement compte des mécanismes de
propagation d'un agent pathogène dans le
monde moderne
parce que et c'est là tout le paradoxe
aujourd'hui à l'heure de l'hyper
technologie des piles à des progrès dans
la maîtrise de la tomme de
l'informatique de la génétique des
biotechnologies l'humanité pourrait se
croire à l'abri alors qu'au contraire
elle est plus que jamais exposés c'est
précisément ce que démontre le rapport
de madame keller douce à dimensions
alarmantes
d'une part évidemment les épidémies
actuelles de cidade ebola ou de
paludisme sont bien là pour nous le
rappeler
les maladies infectieuses sont à
l'origine de 14 millions de décès chaque
année principalement dans les pays du
sud
mais l'incidence des maladies émergentes
a aussi augmenté de 10 à 20 % dans les
pays du nord
ces quinze dernières
cela aussi a été rappelé les maladies
infectieuses représenterait en france 12
% des décès sur les dix principaux
facteurs favorisant l'émergence de
pandémie majeure listés par ordre
d'importance dans le rapport neuf sont
liées à l'activité humaine
plus précisément à l'évolution des
sociétés qu'il s'agisse du changement
d'usagé des sols de la démographie et de
la concentration urbaine de la précarité
des conditions sanitaires ou
hospitalière ou même tout simplement du
réchauffement climatique
mais c'est dans ce lac sur le fond le
rapport nous apparaît encourageant c'est
que si l'humanité responsable de
l'essentiel de la menace c'est qu'elle
dispose aussi des moyens de la prévenir
théoriquement nous devrions pouvoir
rester maître du jeu à condition de s'en
donner les moyens
ce qui conduit naturellement à l'aspect
normatif et décisionnel du rapport celui
qui nous concerne plus directement nous
législateurs et paradoxalement c'est là
que nous manifesterons le plus
d'inquiétudes parce que si nous pouvons
agir force est de le constater
aujourd'hui nous ne sommes pas prêts à
affronter une pandémie meurtrière
c'est le constat nos yeux le plus
authentiquement alarmant du rapport de
fabienne keller
lorsque je dis que nous ne sommes pas
prêt je ne parle même pas de contrer les
facteurs pathogènes de moyen terme
bien sûr nous ne sommes pas prêts à
lutter efficacement contre le
réchauffement climatique
mais c'est là un autre débat je me
concentrerai seulement sur la capacité
de notre système sanitaire à faire face
à une telle menace
pourrait-il réagir efficacement
manifestement non pas à l'échelon
national
le rapport pointe au moins trois
insuffisances majeures du système de
surveillance sanitaire français d'abord
l'absence d'une base épidémiologique
unique contrairement à ce qui existe en
grande bretagne et alors que la france
est concentrée au premier chef et qu'on
pardon est concerné au premier chef
ne serait ce qu'en raison de ces
territoires ultramarins directement
exposés aux maladies tropicales
ensuite la multiplie la multiplicité des
acteurs médecins réseau de surveillance
et agences sanitaires
troisièmement l'insuffisante
identification et capacité d'action de
chacun de ses intervenants
en effet la participation des médecins
traitants à la veille sanitaire est
embryonnaire des réseaux de surveillance
et d'alerté mutualisé sont trop peu
développée l' architecture des agences
sanitaires pourraient être archaïque
concernant ces dernières il pourrait
être question de regrouper l'institut
national de veille sanitaire
et l'institut national de prévention et
d'éducation à la santé pour remettre en
cause la séparation entre veille et
prévention dans ces conditions madame la
ministre une question s'impose nous
savons qu'une loi santé publique est en
préparation à bord dratel ces questions
sur le plan international la situation
n'est guère plus encourageante les
institutions de la coopération
européenne en la matière sont en place
mais elles n'ont qu'un rôle subsidiaire
les membres de mon groupe udi vous le
savez appellent de leurs voeux une
relance de l'intégration communautaire
pour nous l'europe de - doit aussi avoir
une dimension sanitaire les pandémies
font hélas partie de notre histoire
commune
songeons seulement à la peste ces
pandémies font fi des frontières
lorsqu'elle frappe ce sont des
continents qu'elle affecte l'europe et
donc l'échelon pertinent pour une
réponse efficace et coordonnée dans la
même logique bien sûr l'échelon mondial
est aussi une clé et lui non plus ne
semble pas prêt l'un des enseignements
les plus percutants du rapport de
fabienne keller et bien faire apparaître
l'unicité du monde de la pandémie
nous l'avons vu unicité du monde des
hommes le nord étant de plus en plus
vulnérables aux pandémies naissant et
affectant prioritairement le sud
il n'y a pas de sanctuaires heureusement
la coopération internationale s'est
renforcée récemment avec le règlement
sanitaire adopté dans le cadre de l' oms
et qui à force juridique pour la
quasi-totalité des états unis cité au
sein même du vivant dans la mesure où
les principales menaces des maladie
émergente ou réémergente tiennent à
l'existence de zoonoses d'où la
nécessité de lier à l'échelon mondial
médecine animale et humaine
encore une fois madame le ministre nous
ne pouvons que nous tourner vers vous
vers le gouvernement est il prévu que la
france soutienne des programmes de cette
nature
en conclusion je dirais que la menace
dont nous débattons aujourd'hui est
d'autant plus brûlante que nous forts
sont actuellement engagés dans un
conflit armé au mali nous savons que les
guerres notamment dans des pays où règne
la précarité font le lit de pandémie et
souvent il faut garder présent à
l'esprit qu'une attaque cela a été dit
de terrorisme épidémiologique est
toujours possible
ça a été une préoccupation con
avec l'irak qu'on a toujours avec l'iran
ou encore avec la libye compte tenu de
sa situation
je vous remercie monsieur marseille la
parole est à monsieur gilbert barbier
pour le groupe rdse
monsieur le président le ministre
ce le président m'a connu prospection
madame la rapporteure y at il plus
d'émergence maintenant qu'avant c'est
ainsi que s'interroger en avril 2012 le
docteur hélène fagherazzi pagelles dans
son dossier de synthèse pour line east
le cnrs sur les maladies émergentes et
réémergentes chez l'homme
c'est bien la question que vous évoquez
madame keller dans votre remarquable
rapport voulait balayer le trail vaste
champ de cette inquiétude permanente des
pouvoirs publics sur les menaces qui de
tout temps peser sur l'humanité a
longtemps les maladies infectieuses ont
représenté la première cause de
mortalité
le 20e siècle a connu un très net recul
de ces maladies sous la pluie en des
progrès de la médecine du développement
de la prévention de l'amélioration
générale du niveau de lui cette
évolution a culminé à l'éradication de
la variole en 1977
mais depuis lors on l'a observé
l'apparition de maladies nouvelles
souvent l'état les amériques ebola sida
sera ce style virus variant de la
maladie de creutzfeldt-jakob chikungunya
etc
dans le même temps des maladies qui
semblait en déclin comme la dengue la
tuberculose la rougeole ou encore la
coqueluche ont ré émerger en europe
en parallèle et malgré des progrès
récents les infections nosocomiales
survenant à l'hôpital suscite une
inquiétude nouvelle
s'agit-il de faux émergence d'une
amplification médiatique ou bien encore
d'un vrai risque d'émergence le concept
d'émergence n'est pas nouveau il est lié
à la naissance de l'épidémiologie
moderne au 19e siècle discipline de john
snow était le précurseur et se
cristalliser aux états unis avec la
publication d'un rapport en 1992 par
laideur berg et où il envisager maladies
émergentes sous ses aspects
évolutionniste environnementaux sociaux
et politiques
les agents infectieux ont été resteront
les compagnons de route de l'humanité
dans les années 30
charles nicolle énoncés il y aura des
maladies nouvelles elles apparaîtront
comme athéna paru sortant toute armée du
cerveau adulte
comment les reconnaîtrons nous quand
même soupçonnions view nous leur
existence avant qu'elle n'ait revêtu
leur costume de symptômes cette
prédiction repose sur le dynamisme
d'adaptation des agents pathogènes sans
cesse émergent des variantes pour
lesquels nous ne disposons pas de
traitement approprié qu'avec un temps de
retard
les pandémies de grippe du vingtième
siècle sont par exemple dû à des
modifications antigénique des souches de
une fusion de sa virus pas cela étant le
rythme soutenu auquel apparaissent ces
nouvelles maladies
une par an selon m s l'amplitude
géographique et la vitesse de diffusion
en quelques jours pour le bill rice du
strass qui s'est retrouvé sur cinq
continents et a touché 8000 personnes
dans une vingtaine de pays
tout ceci pose aujourd'hui des questions
notre rapport madame keller qui s'appuie
sur l'étude du haut conseil de santé
publique conduite par catherine leport
que vous avez souligné analyse les
facteurs d'émergence et les défis
auxquels sont confrontées les autorités
politiques facteurs d'émergence sont
multiples humain car l'homme est
effectivement l'ingénieur de sa propre
circulation microbienne environnementaux
avec notamment le changement climatique
et des conditions écologiques qui
favorise le passage de la barrière des
espèces médicaux avec les progrès
techniques elles recourent à des gestes
de plus en plus invasif
je ne vais pas ici revenir sinon sur
deux sujets d'inquiétude d'abord
l'apparition de bactéries
multirésistantes extrêmement difficiles
à traiter
dû largement à la surconsommation
d'antibiotiques celui ci est toujours
d'actualité en france mal et malgré les
efforts entrepris avec la campagne les
antibiotiques c'est pas automatique
ensuite la moindre vaccination
l'insuffisance de vaccination dans les
pays en voie de développement est connu
mais force est de constater qu'en europe
et en france des vaccins non plus la
popularité d'antan
d'où la résurgence de la rougeole ou de
la coqueluche dans le rapport du haut
conseil les anthropologues et analyse
les résistances des populations
vis-à-vis de la prévention vaccinale et
le chemin qu'elles parcourent jusqu'à
l'acceptabilité sociale
on ne sait qu on ne saurait se contenter
d'asséner des affirmations sur la
nécessité de se faire vacciner
il vaut mieux comprendre les mécanismes
du refus grâce à des recherches de
sociologie notamment la france est très
en retard dans ce domaine
cette réflexion amène d'ailleurs aborder
les trois défis de l'avenir celui de la
recherche scientifique
l'élu de pays de pasteur que je suis ne
peut oublier l'immense pas en avant que
ce personnage a fait la science avec
cette méthodologie de l'observation à la
base de tous ces travaux je reconnais
madame le rapporteur que je n'oublie pas
que louis pasteur a pris femme à
strasbourg en la personne de la fille du
recteur de l'université de votre ville
aujourd'hui rien qu'en ce qui concerne
les trois principaux fléaux infectieux
mondiaux le paludisme le sida et la
tuberculose nous sommes toujours en
situation d'échec pour les deux premiers
et même pour la tuberculose l'efficacité
du bcg est atténué par la mutation du
bassidj à l'heure des maladies
émergentes ré émergentes aidées
résistance accrue aux traitements le
développement de nouveaux agents
antimicrobiens de nouveaux vaccins est
un défi il faut aussi améliorer
l'acceptabilité l'immunité et la
sécurité en france on disposons de deux
centres de recherche important institut
pasteur le biopôle à lyon de quelques
universités
mais de l'aveu même des acteurs cette
recherche souffre d'une trop grande
fragmentation d'un manque de visibilité
d'un financement peu satisfaisant nous
devons faire de cette décennie la
décennie des vaccins
a déclaré un c'est vrai le donateur au
forum économique de davos en janvier
2010 cela doit être une priorité des
priorités de l' oms de financer la
recherche dans ce domaine même si la
déception est réelle concernant la
dengue ou le chikungunya
pour conclure ce volet scientifique vont
insister sur le décloisonnement les
maladies infectieuses émergentes restent
synonymes de déficit de connaissances et
cause d'importantes incertitudes quand
il est vrai que la complexité des
interactions entre les agents pathogènes
leurs vecteurs et l'homme reste encore à
décrypter
selon une stratégie audacieuse à une
stratégie audacieuse de recherche
interdisciplinaire de la microbiologie
fondamentale jusqu aux sciences humaines
et sociales sans exclusivité permettra
d'avancer des recherches sur la
dynamique des maladies infectieuses se
font grâce au modèle mathématique
toujours plus élaborées en passant par
la génétique et les satellites de
surveillance pour surveiller le climat
les points d'eau les oiseaux bild
cette approche interdisciplinaire
organisations innovantes pour la bien
deux nécessités vitales dans ce domaine
comment s'en donner les moyens de la
ministre des filles a relevé ce sont les
problèmes de l'information les plus
alarmantes ou contradictoires qui
circulent très vite à travers la planète
enfin une des priorités de l' expertise
et donc d'améliorer la communication
avec le grand public des programmes sur
ce sujet devraient être définis dans le
champ de la recherche et de la formation
une approche plus pédagogique des
décisions dans ce mail lui permettrait
de comprendre et accepter la complexité
de ces réalités complexité susceptible
d'aboutir à des changements ou les
revirement de stratégie
à première vue inexplicable pour une
grande majorité de la population mais
parfois des professionnels de santé
le dernier défi c'est l'accès équitable
aux soins la prévention notamment dans
les rapports nord-sud les pays du sud
des maladies infectieuses on a évoqué
leur pourcentage
il est essentiel d détecté suffisamment
tous les flancs bling maladie d'éviter
les épidémies ou l'indemnisation de
certaines maladies
maintenir ou développer la surveillance
et les acteurs de terrain les
équipements et les laboratoires
j'ai noté votre rapport madame reporter
les travaux intéressants avec le docteur
didier bourdon guay chercheur à
l'université de besançon fondateur de
l'unité de recherche qu'il sache ça
ouvre à public démocratique du congo
je crois que c'est des exemples qu'il
faut pouvoir soutenir encourager et à ce
prix nous pourrons lutter contre ces
maladies émergents je vous remercie
merci monsieur barbier dans la suite de
la discussion la parole est à madame
aline archimbaud pour le groupe
écologiste
monsieur le président madame la ministre
monsieur le président de la délégation
sénatoriale à la prospective
madame la rapporteure chers collègues je
voudrais tout d'abord moi aussi remercié
les membres de la délégation sénatoriale
à la prospective pour l'excellent
travail fourni sur l'enjeu technique et
complexe mais néanmoins crucial que sont
les maladies émergentes eu pense bien
sûr aux rapports très documenté rédigé
par madame fabienne keller aux
propositions qu'elle fait informer
prévenir coordonner et à l'ensemble des
analyses que vous avez pu auquel vous
avez pu travailler comme mes collègues
l'ont rappelé avant moi les maladies
émergentes sont à l'origine chaque année
de 14 millions de décès dans le monde
ces maladies parmi lesquels les
tristement célèbres vih strass virus
ebola ou encore grippe h5n1 sont
responsables d'autres collègues l'ont
dit avant moi de 43% du total des décès
constatés chaque année dans les pays du
sud et leur incidence a augmenté de 10 à
20% ces dernières années dans les pays
du nord + 12 % en france je voudrais
rapidement mettre l'accent sur quelques
caractéristiques de ces maladies
émergentes et on me documentant j'ai en
effet vu que des phénomènes que nous
écologistes combattants depuis des
années amplifie la rapidité du
développement de ces maladies est
aujourd'hui une certitude scientifique
et certains l'ont évoquée avant moi les
atteintes à la biodiversité le
changement climatique la déforestation
ou encore l'agriculture et l'élevage
intensif favorise l'apparition ou la
réapparition de ces maladies concernant
la régression de la biodiversité la
disparition de certaines espèces
animales protectrice par exemple des
prédateurs des rongeurs libère des
niches pour les espèces invasives ce qui
favorise en certains cas l'éclosion et
la propagation de maladies infectieuses
certains chercheurs ont travaillé dans
ces domaines vous le savez par exemple
la zoologue keith jones qui insiste sur
le fait que biodiversité gestion
conservatoire restera thouars sont des
moyens de limiter
outre la biodiversité le changement
climatique avec les modifications de
précipitation de l'humidité de la
température qu'il entraîne joue
également un rôle majeur dans
l'accroissement des maladies émergentes
par différents moyens je n'ai pas le
temps de deux développés mais il est
clair que la perturbation de la
composition des écosystèmes des
interactions des espèces entre elles
jouent un rôle et une augmentation
significative des températures est
envisagée dans les années qui viennent
et c'est vrai qu'il faut envisager
parallèlement malheureusement
l'extension géographique d'un certain
nombre de maladies infectieuses
notamment celles transmises par des
animaux vecteur par exemple le paludisme
ou la dengue
par ailleurs autre facteur
l'urbanisation la déforestation la
fragmentation du forez ainsi que
l'intensification de l'agriculture et de
l'élevage favorise l'accroissement de
maladies infectieuses émergentes par
exemple l'augmentation d'élevage
intensif plus sensibles aux maladies
élevages de porcs élevage de volailles
entraîne l'extension des zones où vivent
des espèces vecteurs ou des réservoirs
d'agents pathogènes de même que la
récente sélection chine et génétiques
des plantes les rendent plus sensibles à
certains virus
alors il y a un certain nombre
d'initiation concrètes que je ne
développerai pas longuement je prendrai
un exemple on pourrait en prendre donc
d'autres c'est celui qui nous est
fournie par le virus
jules un responsable de la fièvre
hémorragique d'argentine et dont la
propagation était accentué par la
transformation massive dans ce pays des
terres qui étaient des terres de haute
mer ne prend pas en sang de maïs l'a eu
pour effet de favoriser
la population de rongeurs qui servent de
réservoir à ce virus et qui étaient
auparavant
naturellement régulé par d'autres
espèces qui vivaient dans ces pentes pas
et donc développement d'une culture du
maïs amplifié par l'utilisation
d'herbicides enfin il ya tout un
processus qui a amené la disparition
progressive de zones naturelles sur
lesquelles de façon silencieuse au début
la fièvre cette fièvre hémorragique est
donc devenu épidémique alors je pourrais
citer d'autres exemples
mais j'irai vite un autre point avant de
conclure je rejoins les collègues qui
ont dit qu'il ne fallait pas oublier la
résistance bactérienne qui est en
augmentation et le cas des virus
résistants médicaments ou de leurs
vecteurs résistant aux pesticides qui
représentent environ 20% des 335
maladies émergentes et étudié en février
2008 dans une étude mondiale qui a déjà
été 6/3 en moi en fait un certain nombre
de maladies émergentes sont en fait
d'anciens de maladies qui sont devenus
antibiorésistantes donc par exemple vous
l'avez citer certains collègues avant
moi la tuberculose on estime aujourd'hui
que 25000 malade porteur d' infections
multi-résistantes meurent chaque année
et cette recrudescence s'explique à la
fois par la généralisation des
antibiotiques mais aussi qu'ils sont
présents dans les soins mais aussi dans
présents dans la nourriture animale
de ce point de vue nous ne pouvons que
regretter que la disposition de la loi
kouchner qui avait prévu un médecin
responsable de la modération du sage
d'antibiotiques dans chaque hôpital
n'est finalement jamais été mises en
oeuvre et finalement pour aller pour
aller vite
nous considérons que l'urgence en
matière de lutte contre ces maladies
émergentes et donc la régulation très
encadrée de l'antibiothérapie ainsi que
la protection accrue de la biodiversité
de la lutte contre la déforestation
la modération de l'agriculture et de
l'élevage intensif aussi malheureusement
les négociations internationales sur la
biodiversité le climat se traduisent
souvent par des avancées insuffisantes
au regard des enjeux
en témoignent les échecs relatifs de
conférence récente hyderabad ou doha en
octobre et novembre 2012 et plus
largement ce seront mes derniers mots le
bon état sanitaire d'une population
étant le premier barrage à la maladie
les objectifs de la lutte contre la
pauvreté et l'accès aux soins des
précaires doivent rester en toutes
circonstances une priorité aussi bien en
france que dans le monde et cela même au
delà du seul enjeu des maladies
émergentes
puisque nous connaissons les proportions
inquiétantes dans certains pays de
maladie non émergentes
certaines ont été cités il s'agisse de
la rougeole du paludisme dans sa forme
simple de maladies simplement liés à
l'absence d'eau potable ou même encore
tout simplement malheureusement de la
fin je vous remercie
merci madame archambault dans la suite
de la discussion la parole et à madame
catherine de roche pour le groupe ump
monsieur le président madame la ministre
mes chers collègues à mon tour je tiens
à remercier notre collègue fabienne
keller d'avoir produit au nom de la
délégation à la prospective ce rapport
d'information très complet sur les
nouvelles menaces liées aux maladies
infectieuses émergentes 53 propositions
établies à partir des recommandations de
spécialistes et 10 levier d'action
le professeur claude chastel dans son
ouvrage virus émergents vers de
nouvelles pandémies souligner que parmi
les multiples facteurs qui interviennent
dans l'émergence ou la réémergence de
ces maladies virales l'homme est le
principal responsable
depuis le néolithique il s'est approprié
la planète modifiant détruisant beaucoup
d'écosystèmes
en face on ad'autres entièrement
artificiel
la croissance exponentielle de la
population n'a évidemment fait que
renforcer cette influence de l'homme
sept milliards d'humains sur terre c'est
une aubaine pour des virus entreprenant
qui plus est cette population plus
nombreuse également beaucoup plus mobile
que par le passé les personnes et les
biens se déplace une fréquence et à une
vitesse démultiplier ajoutée aux
changements climatiques à l'évolution
spontanée des agents pathogènes
ces mutations entraîne l'émergence
constante de nouvelles maladies et de
leur diffusion accélérée la surveillance
de ces maladies et le partage des
connaissances existe déjà plusieurs
niveaux au niveau international avec le
géo arn sous l'égide de l'organisation
mondiale de la santé
dans ce cadre le nouveau règlement
sanitaire international rsi adoptée en
2005 par la 58e assemblée mondiale de la
santé a marqué un progrès considérable
en effet ce nouveau récit prend en
compte tous les types de menaces
épidémique
même celles qui sont encore mal définis
mais jugées préoccupantes le rsi permet
donc un signalement rapide entre les
états de toutes menaces sanitaires
pouvant se propager au niveau
international
chaque état a désigné interlocuteur
unique pour la france il s'agit de la
direction générale de la santé qui doit
être en relation 24 heures sur 24 avec
l'om et au niveau européen
le centre européen de prévention et de
contrôle des maladies cdc
identifie évalue la menace que
constituent les maladies infectieuses au
niveau national enfin l'institut de
veille sanitaire et au niveau régional
les agences régionales de santé ars par
l'intermédiaire des cellules de veille
et de gestion des alertes sanitaires
assurent une veille une surveillance
constante de nombreux dispositifs de
veille et d'alerté sanitaire contribue
donc à l'échelle internationale et
nationale à la détection et à l' alerte
des maladies émergentes
ces outils doivent en permanence être
évalués et adaptée pour nous permettre
de préparer des crises en outre d' à
perdre après les diverses expertises
sanitaires effectués dans le monde de
nouvelles maladies infectieuses peuvent
apparaître rapidement et se transformer
en pandémie
à l'instar du strass de la grippe
aviaire ou de la grippe h1n l'inquiétude
porte aussi cela a été dit sur la
résistance de certains virus aux
antibiotiques notamment nazis il est
scientifiquement démontré que la forte
utilisation des antibiotiques a conduit
à l'apparition accéléré de bactéries
très résistantes
c'est pourquoi il faut encourager le
développement de la recherche
nous ne pouvons que nous féliciter la
réalisation d'une nouveau centre
françois jacob à l'institut pasteur de
paris
dévolue aux recherches sur les maladies
émergentes nous connaissons
l'implication des équipes de l'institut
pasteur qui ont été en première ligne
dans les grandes épidémies sera pandémie
grippale chikungunya dès les premiers
cas de chikungunya signalé à la réunion
en 2005
l'institut a monté un projet de
recherche qui a permis de comprendre
l'ampleur inattendue de cette épidémie
notre pays doit donc continuer à
encourager ce type de projet comme le
rappelle arnoud fontanes et chef de
licques l'unité d'épidémiologie des
maladies et pearl jantes de l'institut
les maladies émergentes sont toutes ces
maladies qui apparaissent au sein des
populations humaines
ce sont aussi les maladies anciennes ou
presque disparu qui raymer joe colonise
de nouvelles zones géographiques
elles sont le plus souvent infectieuses
c'est à dire qu'elles sont dues à des
micro organismes comme les bactéries
virus parasites champignons en plus des
décès et des douleurs qu'elle entraîne
ces pathologies en conséquence sur tous
les pans de la société
ralentissement économique entrave à la
circulation des biens des personnes
enfin je pense que nous venons nous
devons mener une réflexion poussée afin
de définir des protocoles opérationnel
pour une bonne utilisation d'internet et
des réseaux sociaux en cas de crise
sanitaire
internet est une formidable source
d'information aussi de désinformation et
de fausses rumeurs il serait sûrement
utile de nous inspirer de la stratégie
des états unis
décrite par le député jean pierre door
au centre d'atlanta le centre pour le
contrôle et la prévention des maladies
plus de 400 personnes surveillent les
réseaux sociaux 24 heures sur 24 en
répondant immédiatement à tous les
messages les résultats sont au rendez
vous nous en sommes loin chez nous la
délégation interministérielle à la lutte
contre la grippe aviaire disposait de
huit personnes nous devons
impérativement renforcer ses moyens pour
lutter efficacement contre les diffusion
sur internet de toutes les rumeurs
fantaisistes qui crée entretiennent la
panique
c'est pourquoi j'approuve totalement la
proposition de fabienne keller
d'expérimenter une situation de
potentiel crise avec tous les acteurs
concernés ceux de la santé bien sûr
médecins et chercheurs jeu mais aussi
les représentants des différents
services de l'état les représentants des
collectivités locales et autres
notamment je partage son point de vue
quant à la nécessité d'anticiper un
scénario-catastrophe correspondant à la
conjonction des pires hypothèses une
maladie inconnue une incubation rapide à
forte létalité à la transmission
incontrôlable et contre laquelle aucun
traitement ne saurait être efficace la
question des maladies infectieuses
émergentes mérite donc toute notre
attention et nous impose d'améliorer
constamment la protection de la
population afin d'éviter l'émergence
d'une crise sanitaire de grande ampleur
sur notre territoire
je vous remercie merci madame de roche
la parole est à monsieur ronan kerdraon
monsieur le président madame la ministre
monsieur le président de la délégation à
la prospective n'dam le rapporteur mes
chers collègues je tiens tout d'abord à
saluer la qualité du travail de notre
collègue de notre collègue fabienne
keller pour ce rapport très complet sur
les maladies infectieuses émergentes
ces maladies constitue de nos jours une
menace réelle et permanente elle l'a
très bien démontré
elle touche et mobilise aussi bien les
pays du nord et ceux du sud
la lutte contre ces maladies nécessitent
donc la mobilisation des puissances
publiques recherche information
coordination et prévention doivent donc
être les maîtres mots en la matière une
maladie infectieuse émergents peut
aujourd'hui se définir comme une entité
clinique d'origine infectieuse
nouvellement apparus et identifiés ou
comme une maladie infectieuse connue et
dont les caractéristiques évoluent dans
un espace où au sein même d'un groupe de
population les derniers travaux sur les
causes de l'émergence montre des
interactions multiples et rapidement
changeante entre différents facteurs
comme lot l'agent infectieux
l'environnement cela sur fond de grande
diversité biologique
face à ces risques infectieux la
surveillance des maladies évolué et doit
s'orienter en amont c'est à dire vers
les fines cliniques les agents
infectieux les vecteurs le monde animal
et l'environnement afin d'anticiper
l'apparition de situations à risque
d'émergence outré émergence et c'est
dans cette perspective que le
renforcement de la collaboration avec
les réseaux et institutions
internationaux est indispensable voire
décisive
une approche globale apparaît alors
nécessaires pour mieux comprendre et
faire face à ces multiples évolutions
nous devons combiner nos forces entre
les pays du nord disposant d'outils de
moyens et les pays du sud zone plus
propice à l'émergence
cette émergence effectué chez l'homme en
deux étapes par l'introduction surprise
d'un nouvel agent pathogène et ou par la
dissémination dans une population non
immunologiquement préparer notons mes
chers collègues ainsi que l'a fait
fabienne keller contre 1940 et 2004 plus
de 335 maladies infectieuses ont été
découvertes et les causes sont toujours
les mêmes baisse de la vigilance des
systèmes de contrôle acquisition de
mécanismes de résistance
so médicaments anti-infectieux
modification de l'écosystème
elle a effectivement souligné la
déforestation la création de zones
suburbaines ou le déplacement de
population bien évidemment d'autres
éléments sont à prendre en compte la
mondialisation des échanges
l'augmentation du commerce international
des éléments l'essor de l'écotourisme
les contacts rapprochons l'animal de
l'homme les animaux étant c'est vrai
dans plus de 70% des cas à l'origine de
ces infections
l'utilisation également de maladies
infectieuses à des fins terroristes cela
a été souligné tout à l'heure et enfin
les changements climatiques
nous pourrions également cité dans une
moindre mesure la dégradation des
infrastructures également de santé
publique
incapable de faire face aux besoins de
certaines populations
face à cette situation la msa développer
et coordonner en 2000 le réseau mondial
d'alerté et d'action en cas d'épidémie
qui relie plusieurs réseaux de
surveillance
il s'agissait de détecter les maladies
infectieuses émergentes de déterminer
leur menace potentielle pour la santé
publique et d'établir des interventions
efficaces
certains de ces réseaux sont
spécifiquement conçus pour repérer des
événements inhabituels qui soit
d'origine naturelle accidentelle ou
délibérée les épidémies les plus
fréquemment notifiés ont été le choléra
la grippe le strass la méningite les
fièvres hémorragiques virales la peste
la fièvre jaune et l'aisance fatalité
les amphétamines pardon virales les
progrès dans le domaine de l'hygiène et
de la santé publique
peuvent-ils faire espérer une diminution
de la mortalité par maladies
transmissibles dans les pays en voie de
développement
malheureusement des progrès ne peuvent
être obtenus que s'ils n'assistent pas à
l'émergence de nouvelles infections ou à
la réémergence de maladies actuellement
contrôlés et surtout si aucune
résistance majeure aux antibiotiques aux
antiviraux ne s'installe de plus
l'explosion démographique l'urbanisation
anarchique provoque de bouvet de
profonds bouleversements à l'origine de
pathologies transmissibles
certains des nouveaux agents qui ont été
détectés au cours de ces 25 dernières
années pose maintenant de sérieux
problèmes de santé publique à l'échec
à l'échelle locale régionale ou mondiale
nous faisons face à un autre problème de
santé publique par rapport à
l'augmentation rapide
du nombre de bactéries qui deviennent
résistantes à une gamme de plus en plus
étendues d'antibiotiques dans beaucoup
de régions les antibiotiques de première
intention
peu coûteux ont perdu leur efficacité ce
qui de ce fait un impact économique
puisqu'il accroît le coût et la durée du
traitement de nombreuses maladies
courantes comme les maladies
diarrhéiques épidémique ou la pneumonie
nous parlons aussi de maladies
infectieuses réémergentes quand on
observe la réapparition une augmentation
d'infection connu mais devenu si rare
qu'elles n'étaient plus considérés comme
des problèmes de santé publique la mise
en place des mesures de prévention
contre les nouvelles maladies
infectieuses nécessite donc une
collaboration étroite entre les médecins
les chercheurs les décideurs et
l'ensemble de la population dans le
cadre de ce qu'il est appelé de manière
convenue une politique de santé publique
une stratégie audacieuse de recherche de
formation pour une aide plus efficace à
la gestion des situations d'émergence de
maladies infectieuses et une
organisation innovante devrait pourrait
être inscrite dans une loi de santé
publique
en effet la nature même de ces maladies
infectieuses émergentes est synonyme de
déficit de connaissances et génèrent
d'importantes incertitudes
il en ressort donc un besoin urgent
d'acquisition de partage des savoirs que
seul peut satisfaire une étroite
collaboration entre recherche
enseignement et recherche action ainsi
mes chers collègues comme je viens de
l'exposer nous devons nous nous devons
de nous retrouver autour d'un but commun
et dans un esprit transversale entre
approches médicales écologiques
économiques sociologiques et politiques
dans cette optique nous devons donner à
notre recherche à nos chercheurs les
moyens nécessaires pour analyser et
interpréter il faut des moyens humains
mais aussi logistique pour réussir à
dégager de nouvelles propositions de
recherche et d'action pour produire un
bilan annuel sur l'état de la lutte
contre ces maladies et sur l'état
d'avancement de la mise en application
de ces recommandations par les
organismes et instances auxquelles elles
sont destinées
enfin la diffusion de ces travaux
devrait contribuer à mieux sensibiliser
les professionnels et les citoyens à ce
genre de risque
développer la recherche et l'information
c'est comprendre de façon plus
approfondie le rôle des espèces haute
les vecteurs et améliorer la
connaissance sur ces systèmes émergents
notamment dans les pays tropicaux en
stimulant une politique scientifique de
coopération internationale en améliorant
la capacité de notre recherche
biomédicale nous encouragerons la
recherche sur le contexte économique
historique sociale et culturelle de la
santé humaine et animale
une analyse fine des situations de crise
devrait également susciter une meilleure
adhésion aux politiques mises en oeuvre
en élaborant un programme de recherche
interdisciplinaire en collaboration avec
les acteurs de terrain
nous soutiendrons favoriseront les
contributions des sciences humaines et
sociales dans la formation des
spécialistes des pays du sud
que ce soit en master doctorat ou en
post doctorat particulièrement ce qui
concerne la prise en compte des cultures
et des savoirs locaux
la préparation à la gestion des
situations critiques devrait dépendre
d'une coordination interministérielle
permanente
l'impact de ces maladies et on a
complètement prévisible
pourquoi ne pas non plus instaurer mes
chers collègues un fonds d'urgence
lequel viendrait renforcer les moyens
indispensables à la recherche à
l'identification et à l'évaluation du
risque
aussi monsieur le président madame la
ministre monsieur madame parent dont le
rapporteur
mes chers collègues je pense que nous
devrions porter notre réflexion et nos
moyens sous la recherche et
l'enseignement afin de donner à nos
spécialistes les moyens nécessaires à la
protection des populations face à cette
maladie
je vous remercie
merci monsieur carnahan je m'attends
passer la parole à madame la ministre
des affaires sociales et de la santé
madame la ministre
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
président la délégation à la prospective
madame la rapporteure mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs je voudrais vous
remercier pour la qualité du débat qui
vient de se dérouler et nous avons pu
mesurer nous pouvons mesurer toute
l'importance qu'il y a à définir la
manière dont nous concevons la
protection de notre société et à
l'intérieur de la société de chacun de
nos concitoyens face à la perspective de
risques émergents ou à la réémergence de
certains risques parmi lesquels figurent
les maladies infectieuses est le
principal constat du rapport
d'information de madame keller qui a été
écrit au nom de la délégation
sénatoriale à la prospective sur les
nouvelles menaces des maladies
infectieuses émergentes réside bien dans
le fait qu'en dépit des immenses progrès
réalisés par la recherche médicale
nos sociétés restent fragiles je veux
vous remercier madame ainsi que
l'ensemble de la délégation sénatoriale
pour la qualité du travail dont nous
discutons aujourd'hui le contenu riche
et documentée du rapport assorti de
propositions concrètes doivent nous
permettre d'avancer j'en suis certaine
dans ce domaine majeur pour la santé
publique
les activités humaines nous avons ont
souvent été à l'origine du développement
et de l'implantation des maladies
infectieuses
nous savons par exemple que la variole
la rougeole la grippe ont été
introduites dans le nouveau monde par
les colonisateurs espagnols et en retour
ces derniers ont été confrontés à la
fièvre jaune dans ces pays et ils ont
ensuite diffusé le typhus en europe ces
enjeux ne sont pas dépassés vous avez
été très nombreux à évoquer la grippe
espagnole mais ces enjeux ne sont pas
dépassés ils n'appartiennent pas
seulement à l'histoire et
aujourd'hui encore de nombreux facteurs
peuvent concourir à la diffusion il ya
l'émergence parfois brutales de maladies
infectieuses je pense en particulier à
l'accélération et à la mondialisation
des échanges à la concentration de plus
en plus importante de population dans
des mégalopoles ou à la modification du
climat
en parallèle ou face à cela on peut
constater que les agents pathogènes eux
ont réveillé d'exceptionnel capacité
d'adaptation et donc nous devons
évidemment faire attention jeu j'ai
entendu aussi que dans la discussion qui
a eu lieu ont été évoqués la résurgence
les résurgence de maladies qui
apparaissait comme disparus ou en tout
cas contenu certaines particulièrement
préoccupante d'autres qui sont moins
graves je pense à la gale qui a été
évoqué et que l'on associe dans notre
esprit à des populations en précarité
que l'on croyait réservées aux
populations défavorisées alors que on
s'aperçoit que c'est plutôt réservé à
des collectivités de personnes et j'ai
par exemple saisie sur cette question le
haut conseil de la santé publique pour
que soit évalué la situation et que soit
formulé des recommandations parce que
c'est une maladie qui n'est pas grave
mais qui pose quand même des problèmes
quotidiens et un contre est extrêmement
désagréable
au delà nous devons si nous voulons
préparer l'avenir
anticiper et agir autour je crois de
quatre axes majeurs la prévention la
détection la coopération et la
préparation de la population
la prévention d'abord et le président de
la république l'a rappelé effectivement
dans son discours de clôture du 40ème
congrès de la mutualité française à nice
l'enjeu majeur de nos politiques de
santé publique dans les années à venir
c'est bien la prévention mieux prévenir
et cela a été souligné
c'est d'abord améliorer la couverture
vaccinale en mettant en place une
stratégie nationale pour les cinq
prochaines années ce programme doit
tirer les enseignements des échecs
passés
je pense en particulier aux écueils que
nous avons rencontrés lors des campagnes
de vaccination contre la pandémie
grippale et contre l'épidémie actuelle
de rougeole
j'ajouterai que je suis préoccupé de
voir que face à une maladie aussi banal
au sens strict du terme que la grippe
les personnes à risque est identifié
comme tel ont un taux de vaccination qui
a été en diminution
cette année déjà l'année dernière et que
je suis également préoccupé de voir que
face à cette maladie de la grippe
les personnels soignants dans nos
établissements de santé restent une
petite minorité à se faire vacciner il y
à là me semble-t-il un enjeu important
mieux prévenir c'est aussi et j'ajoute
parce que je ne sais plus qui l'a évoqué
dans son intervention mais il y à des
résistances française à la vaccination
qu'il nous faut arriver à mieux cerner
par rapport à ce que l'on voit dans
d'autres pays
même si globalement nous atteignons des
résultats qui malgré tout reste
satisfaisant mieux prévenir c'est aussi
mieux contrôler l'usagé des
antibiotiques vous avez été à certains
nombres à le dire si nous voulons
maîtriser l'apparition de résistances
aux antibiotiques et j'ai bien entendu
le regret exprimé par madame aline
archambault par rapport à ce qui aurait
dû se mettre en place dans le
prolongement de la loi dite kouchner du
4 mars 2002 eh bien je souhaite que se
met en place dans chaque femme pour
chaque établissement de santé
la possibilité de recourir à un référent
en antibiothérapie nous devrions avancer
dans les prochaines semaines il nous
faudra également envisagée
une réflexion sur l'utilisation des
antibiotiques chez les animaux par
rapprochement des spécialistes en santé
animale et en santé humaine autour de ce
qui s'est répandue comme étant le
concept one une seule santé qui
évidemment doit pouvoir prospérer
chez nous aussi le deuxième axe je le
disais c'est celui au delà de la
prévention du renforcement de nos
capacités de détection d' alerte et de
réponse aux signaux notre action passera
par une amélioration de la gouvernance
régionale et nationale
à l'origine la sécurité sanitaire est
défini comme la sécurité des personnes
contre les risques liés au
fonctionnement du système de santé
ce concept est aujourd'hui beaucoup plus
large
il s'étend aux risques liés au
fonctionnement de la société
c'est à dire au risque alimentaire aux
risques environnementaux et aux risques
médicaux et c'est d'ailleurs sous le
signe de la sécurité sanitaire ont été
placés les dispositifs de lutte contre
les menaces épidémique
le système de veille sanitaire est
perfectible assurément et nous devons
aujourd'hui améliorer ses capacités de
détection d' alerte et de réponse en
premier lieu nous devons inciter les
professionnels de santé à la déclaration
des vigilances et des épisodes non
seulement récent mais en cours nous en
ont montré la nécessité
cette question sera pour moi une
priorité dans le cadre de la stratégie
nationale de santé à laquelle je
travaille une refonte du système de
vigilance est en cours de réalisation et
aboutir à cette année il s'agit ensuite
de valoriser la veille sanitaire
régionale en déployant des réseaux en
santé publique avec la médecine générale
il nous faut véritablement considérer
les médecins généralistes comme de
véritables vie
j de santé publique et je le dis je
pense que dans le passé à l'occasion
d'événements récents nous n'avons pas
suffisamment nous ne nous sommes pas
suffisamment appuyée sur les
professionnels de santé en particulier
les médecins généralistes
je crois que c'est une des raisons qui
explique l'échec dans la prise en charge
de la menace d'une pandémie grippale à
l'occasion de la grippe donc dit à shine
le troisième axe de notre action doit
être celui du renforcement de la
coopération internationale notamment pas
uniquement mais notamment en direction
des pays émergents
le règlement sanitaire international
adopté par 194 états lors de l'assemblée
mondiale de la santé le 23 mai 2005
renforce les contrôles sanitaires dans
les lieux des changes il vise à
améliorer la coordination internationale
en instaurant un réseau mondial unique
de gestion des alertes sanitaires
ce règlement n'avait pas de traduction
concrète pour être mises en oeuvre dans
notre pays
c'est chose faite depuis la signature la
publication au journal officiel le 9
janvier 2013 de cette année du décret
relatif à sa mise en oeuvre
j'ai par ailleurs pu observer lors de
mes déplacements dans différents pays
européens au cours des derniers mois de
la nécessité de rationaliser et
renforcer les capacités et les
structures de l'union européenne pour
faire face à l'émergence des maladies
infectieuses les menaces sanitaires par
principe ne connaissent pas les
frontières et nous devons donc jeter les
bases d'une approche élargies et
coordonnées au niveau de l'union
européenne c'est à partir de là que nous
pouvons approfondir la coopération avec
les pays du sud qui reste aujourd'hui
les premières victimes de ces maladies
enfin nous devons tirer des
enseignements de la pandémie grippale
h1n1 notamment en termes de perception
des risques et de comportement de la
population pour être efficaces les
mesures préventives mises en place par
les
autorités sanitaires doivent être
compréhensible et comprises de la part
de fin pour nos concitoyens et de leur
part la qualité de la communication vous
avez raison madame la sénatrice keller
de le souligner est déterminante
si nous voulons partager une culture
commune sur le risque émergent pour
anticiper et pour clarifier les rumeurs
infondées
nous avons une responsabilité pour
relayer au plus près de la population et
des acteurs locaux des messages factuel
informatif cohérent et précis trouver le
juste équilibre entre l'exigence de ne
pas inquiéter outre mesure tout en
informant et en permettant une
protection de qualité de ceux de se
mettre en place un centre de crise a été
inauguré il ya quelques mois à peine au
ministère des affaires sociales et de la
santé qui nous permettent nous permet
désormais de mettre en place des
exercices d'anticipation plus efficace
pour tester nos capacités de réponse à
titre d'exemple les capacités de
mobilisation et d'organisation des
médecins des hôpitaux des agences
régionales de santé et des différents
acteurs nationaux ont été testés dans le
domaine des pathologies vectorielle
comme le chikungunya et de la réponse
anti vectorielle
vous plaidez madame la sénatrice pour
que nous allions au delà pour des
exercices d'anticipation politique qui
réunirent est différent ou plusieurs
ministères et pas simplement le
ministère de la santé
l'idée d'un exercice national de
prospective qui mettrait en relation au
delà des ministères différents métiers
et toutes les professions concernées
avant que ne survienne une nouvelle
pandémie est séduisante et vous avez
oeuvré dans ce sens en organisant en mai
dernier
l'atelier de prospective vous avez ainsi
ouvert la voie à une réflexion dans ce
sens réflexion que je sois je souhaite
que nous puissions poursuivre il ne
m'appartient pas de définir une
stratégie au niveau interministériel
seulement pour en ce qui me concerne le
ministère de la santé
mais je souhaite en tout cas que nous
puissions
réfléchir en gaz elle a engagé la
réflexion avec les acteurs non
institutionnelle justement des
sociologues des acteurs de la société
civile pour voir comment gérer ces
événements
lorsqu'ils se produisent et je verrai
avec mes collègues ou avec les autres
ministères comment nous pouvons avancer
dans ce sens la stratégie nationale de
santé accordera une place majeure à la
gestion des nouvelles menaces des
maladies infectieuses émergentes et des
nouvelles menaces tout court votre
principal objectif est bien de protéger
la population en anticipant et en
travaillant en amont avec tout le monde
dans ce but il nous faut conduire une
politique volontariste de prévention
améliorer les mécanismes de surveillance
sanitaire et marquer la confiance que
nous devons avoir envers les médecins de
proximité
c'est un travail important est lourd et
je vous remercie de nous permettre de le
mener dans de bonnes conditions
merci madame la ministre
merci mes chers collègues merci madame
la rapporteure c'est la fin de ce débat
consacré aux nouvelles maladies
infectieuses émergentes si vous
souhaitez le revoir et les disponible en
vod sur notre site internet
publicsenat.fr très bonne journée à tous